لقد حظيت بشرف
وسعادة متميزين لأنك حصلت على
بعض رسائل البريد الإلكتروني الخاصة بك والتي تم إصدارها
للجمهور خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية
أه وكانت هناك أسئلة أو
جدل تم طرحها
ولكن بعض الأسئلة أثيرت حول
بعضها وأنا  تريد تسجيلك في
السجل
يخاطب بعضًا منهم ، فقد تم
إرسال بريد إلكتروني إليك من مسؤول تنفيذي في eco
health alliance وهذه إحدى
الشركات التي مولت بعض
الأبحاث في مختبر ووهان
وهذا البريد الإلكتروني يشكرك على
قولك بشكل أساسي  كنت تعتقد أن
أصول الفيروس التاجي كانت طبيعية ،
قال هذا البريد الإلكتروني الاقتباس
أريد أن أقول شكراً شخصياً
نيابة عن موظفينا والمتعاونين لدينا
للوقوف علناً والقول إن الأدلة العلمية
تدعم الأصل الطبيعي لـ covid19
من الخفافيش إلى الإنسان  غير منتشر
ليس إصدارًا مختبريًا من معهد ووهان
لعلم الفيروسات أن البريد الإلكتروني
كان يوم 18 أبريل ، والآن هناك
بعض نقادك الذين يقولون إن هذا يظهر أنك تشعر
بالراحة الشديدة  الابتهاج مع
الأشخاص الذين يقفون وراء أبحاث مختبر ووهان ،
ما الذي تقوله لذلك ،
هذا هراء ، لا أرى حتى كيف
حصلوا على ذلك من هذا البريد
الإلكتروني الذي تم إرساله إليّ من البريد الإلكتروني الذي
قلته دائمًا وسأقول لك اليوم جون  أنني
ما زلت أعتقد أن الأصل الأكثر ترجيحًا
هو من نوع حيواني إلى
إنسان ، لكني أبقى منفتحًا تمامًا على
أنه إذا كانت هناك أصول أخرى
لذلك ، فقد يكون هناك سبب آخر
كان من الممكن أن يكون تسربًا معملًا ، أعتقد
إذا نظرت تاريخيًا
ما يحدث في واجهة الإنسان للحيوان ،
وهو في الواقع أن
الاحتمال
الأكبر هو أنك تتعامل مع قفزة من
الأنواع ، لكنني أبقى
متفتحًا طوال الوقت وهذا هو
السبب في أنني كنت علنيًا
لذلك يجب أن نستمر في البحث عن
أصل
هذا البريد الإلكتروني لا يمكنك بأي حال من الأحوال أن تسيء
فهمه ،
ولكنك تريد أن يكون هذا البريد الإلكتروني من
شخص لي يقول شكراً لك على كل ما
كان يعتقد أنني
قلته وقلت إنني أعتقد أن الأصل الأكثر احتمالاً
هو قفز الأنواع.  ما زلت أعتقد
أنه
في نفس الوقت الذي أكون فيه منفتحًا على
أنه قد يكون دوريًا معملًا ،
ثم أخيرًا كان هناك بريد إلكتروني
منك إلى سيلفيا بورويل سكرتيرة سموها السابقة
التي تتعلق
بالأقنعة وهذا هو  الحصول على قدر كبير من
الاهتمام ، حيث أن التاريخ هنا هو الخامس من فبراير ،
والذي أعتقد أنه مهم للغاية ، لقد سألتك على
ما يبدو عما إذا كان
ينبغي لها ارتداء قناع
في رحلة ، وقد استجبت لها في
الختام ، ولا أوصي
بارتداء قناع خاصة منذ ذلك الحين.  كنت
ذاهبًا إلى
موقع منخفض المخاطر للغاية في الخامس من فبراير
، حدث الكثير منذ ذلك الحين إذا كان عليك
العودة والقيام بذلك مرة أخرى ،
فهل ستخبرها بشيء مختلف ،
هل تندم على ذلك
جيدًا أنك تعرف جون ، دعنا نتحقق هنا
إذا كنت  انظر إلى المعلومات العلمية
لأنها تجمع
ما يجري في كانون الثاني (يناير) وفبراير (شباط)
ما تعرفه
كحقيقة حيث أن البيانات توجه
ما تخبر الناس به
وسياساتك في حالة حدوث شهر أبريل / نيسان ، فإنك
تجمع الكثير من
المعلومات  د تقوم بتعديل
وتعديل رأيك وتوصياتك بناءً على
العلم الحالي والبيانات الحالية ، لذلك بالطبع
إذا علمنا في ذلك الوقت أن قدرًا كبيرًا
من الإرسال كان
أشخاصًا بدون أعراض إذا علمنا
أن البيانات تظهر أن الأقنعة خارج
إطار المستشفى
تعمل فعلاً عندما لم نكن نعرف
ذلك ، إذا أدركنا كل هذه الأشياء في
ذلك الوقت ،
بالطبع ، ستطرح سؤالاً هل
كنت ستفعل شيئًا مختلفًا إذا كنت
تعرف ما تعرفه
الآن بالطبع كان الناس قد فعلوا
ذلك  واضح جدا